Aisha's story is one of abuse abuse in
the name of honor the moment her parents
found out she had a white boyfriend life
was never the same I was essentially
under house arrest you know I'm trapped
in the house I can't go anywhere
um there was no end in sight it was it
was terrifying
at the age of 22 from South Wales her
parents took Aisha back to India on a
false pretense they claimed her grandma
was unwell but in fact they wanted to
force her into a marriage with a man
she'd never met I was also threatened
with
um violence from the sort of local I
suppose you'd call them majah hadains
and so my dad told me quite plainly that
if they knew what I had done they would
shoot me my mother had insinuated
um that there could be you know even
worse retributions uh fatal
when she returned home married against
her will only then did she manage to
escape the constant coercive control of
her parents
like thousands of women across the UK
she is now a survivor of honor-based
abuse but some aren't so lucky
20 years ago shafilia Ahmed was murdered
by her own family it was a brutal death
that sparked a national conversation
to help identify more cases of
honor-based abuse and prosecute
perpetrators campaigners hope a new
definition will be recognized by the
British government it's really vitally
important that those that are on the
front line that have an opportunity to
identify it such as police officers
social workers and health professionals
who are the touch points really for
victims that they have a real clear
understanding through a clear definition
of what it is to be able to offer the
best support
the charity also claims policing around
this issue has regressed so as well as
introducing this definition they're
demanding a re-inspection of forces
across the country
at Heathrow Airport the minister for
safeguarding was Keen to show the
government's proactive Approach at the
moment the strategy definition might not
be helpful but I'm going to look at that
and I will look and listen with
everybody else in the home office and we
will consider whether there needs to be
a change but at the moment we do have
definitions of domestic abuse and
honor-based abuse
this issue is entrenched in cultural and
traditional complexities but knowing
exactly what honor-based abuse is and
what it looks like could be the
beginning of ending this Injustice in
saman Rasheed Sky News Warrington